[Music]
all right let's go to chris let's go to
chris in san tan valley arizona what's
up chris
how you doing john
uh hey i'm super nervous about jumping
out of an airplane other than i'm doing
great how are you man
i'm doing good i'd be nervous about
jumping out of an airplane too you know
why because it's insane but good that's
all that's glad we're on the same page
there what's up brother how can i help
man
so recently uh
on my job site i spoke during safety
week about my experience with mental
health and anxiety and i've gotten a lot
of really good responses out of it and
i'm just i'm i want to help these people
and so i'm wondering like what's the
next logical step
or what's the next step that i should do
here
um what's the job site man
uh
i can't give you the name of it but it's
a it's a very large job site there's
probably
a thousand construction workers oh
construction dude you had a
mental health conversation with
construction workers
yep yep
hey let me like
i need you to hear me say this
there are a few people i assign the word
hero to and what you do is heroic
that's a thank you big deal man
because construction's hard and it's got
its own its own culture to it in its own
suck it upness and its own
very man i i'm serious dude that's
inspiring man
good for you
and so tell me about how the
conversation went
uh it was i've had a lot of
conversations with people afterwards um
there's been at least four people that i
know of that after i got up and talked
about it they reached out to their
company's helplines they went and got
professional help wow there's been a
couple of people that after we talked
one-on-one after that
you know they started taking their
medications again
and just a lot of good positive results
people are getting help
and they're helping themselves and
because of this and like i got the
momentum going right now and i've got
the attention on it and i just i want to
keep driving it and keep
trying to find these people that that
need help and
you know we're swapping stories of
of how we're learning to
deal with our mental health issues and
go through it and dealing with life with
this
with these extra issues so
uh
i've thought of starting up maybe a
support group i thought about maybe
trying to figure out a way to keep
pushing the awareness out there and keep
talking about it and i'm just i guess
i'm looking for a direction i need some
help
man okay so
they don't make a lot of you man they
broke the mold when you were when you
were came off the line dude so it's an
honor to get to talk to you thank you
for your heart thank you for your
vulnerability your willingness to be
open with folks
and for everybody listening
this is what the world needs right here
is people to stand up in their area in
their group with the with the with the
audience they have which may be an
audience of five pta moms and it may be
an audience of
5 000 construction workers
rolling their eyes through a safety
training and then all of a sudden
somebody comes up and says hey this
happened to me good for you man this is
this is what the we do not need a bunch
of a bunch more politicians yelling at
each other we need more chris's in the
world so thank you
uh all right so i'm gonna tell you a
couple of thoughts i have moving forward
and then i'm gonna challenge you on one
or two things is that cool
cool sounds good all right the first
thing is i wrote down while you were
talking set up a recurring group so same
team jinx right i think that's wise
i think it would be really cool here's
what i'm going to provide you i'm going
to mail you 10 copies for free of
redefining anxiety okay i'm going to
just ship them to you in a box you can
hand out like tic tacs to people okay
and it's it's um
really thin it's like 70 or 80 pages
it's really thin
and it's about dealing with anxiety and
what it is what it's not how to get your
life back that's the subtitle okay
but it's it's not you don't have to have
a phd to get through it it's a very
simple mental health um awareness book
for folks and then it gives them some
tools so you'll be able to be a resource
there
also if i'm not crazy
this is a particular industry that is um
it's very challenging financially for
some of the the the tradesmen
and so i'm gonna send you 10
10
ramsey plus subscriptions you know i
work with dave ramsey here and that
includes the financial peace university
so here's what i'm saying a class you
could kick up
is to teach the financial peace class
and offer
um for a year the app and folks for
folks who want to show up to this class
so i'm going to send you 10 of those for
free okay
and if you what you're going to do is
you're going to teach these folks how to
how to deal with their money what some
of their challenges are and here's what
happens when you teach someone how to
deal with their money they have to sit
down with their spouse and have a hard
conversation about values and about
togetherness and about doing things
differently and changing family trees
in little tiny wins and paying off debt
and all of those track with getting on
track men with your mental health too
getting connected with other people and
changing your behaviors and changing
your actions and planning and being
intentional all those things right so if
you want to have a class that is hey
we're just going to talk about what's
going on in your life challenges you're
having where you can be heard great
if you want to have a class on how to
deal with your money some tactical
things we're gonna have a we're gonna
i'm gonna kick this class up and we're
gonna do that too okay so i'm gonna take
care of you on both of those fronts just
as my gift to you
oh that is amazing thank you you got it
man thank you um so
here's my challenge to you okay
you are feeling the other side of
of being vulnerable which is other
people reach out to you and they say you
made a difference in my life thank you
incredible
and in my life i'll just speak about me
i have to be careful because that is a
powerful intoxicating drug
and what i can do if i'm not careful is
begin looking for where everybody's
going through problems
and i start trying to insert myself and
solve them or come up with another thing
and another thing and another thing
you see what i'm saying
and over time it becomes about me not
other people so here's my challenge to
you
the goal now that you have established
this as you've established yourself as a
safe person and you've established this
is something we're going to talk about
in this company and on these job sites
this is just who be is going to be who
we are
is to
create a referral system for a therapist
in your area
ask a local counselors if they'll come
speak once a month at these groups
i go meet um once once a semester i go
meet with the celebrate recovery group
here in town just as a local expert like
hey when i pick your brain about this
and i end up walking away with way more
than those guys did
um
but
bring experts into this conversation who
can facilitate groups who can have some
of these deeper conversations and maybe
partner with some of these construction
companies to say hey we got a group of
guys who are struggling will you guys
pay for x or pay for y it will help
everybody the roi will be will be more
than 150 bucks you're spending for that
one hour for for donuts and coffee and a
therapist to come give a lecture on fill
in the blank but you see what i'm saying
we're gonna we're gonna transition the
expertise from you
to a series of experts and a series of
a system if you will that's going to be
a network of people so people can get
plugged in where they need to get
plugged in does that make sense
total sense okay am i out to lunch there
or can you go oh yeah i can see that
happening
i could see that happening and i
i think that would be the right
path ultimately okay okay
um
what are some
key things that have come up in your
conversations
a lot of it's been around
a lot of it has been around i'm not sure
if i have issues okay you know you and i
i always
kick people up to either their helpline
or reach out
um
let's have to say another big thing that
keeps
coming up is like we're just swapping
stories we're just encouraging one
another and
um
it turns into it do you think i should
reach out to somebody yes i do and then
like a week later i end up having a
follow-up conversation great uh and then
they talk and we talk about it and then
we we kind of share it and it's
been interesting how
with me going through my mental health
experience how much it's connected with
other people going through their mental
health experience because we get each
other almost in a way that
other people don't that's exactly right
yeah
so
one thing that you could do that would
be really powerful is to
make the conversation less about
quote-unquote mental health issues
and more about people getting together
and doing life together
and this is one of those things that i
didn't fully get
until i went down the loneliness rabbit
hole
but
everybody's got challenges in their life
and it's when we try to solve all these
challenges by ourselves
week after week month after month year
after year that they turn into
pathologies over time that's not always
the case people have true mental illness
that's different than mental health
challenges
but
over time it's the accumulation it's the
pile up of this stuff
and you know it can be a great thing as
a softball league
or
a
we all go throw darts on such and such
and you better not miss so we're all
gonna text you and harass you and call
you right because you're one of us
places where people can get together and
do life the amount of money the company
where i work
spends on
community interaction just eating
together and playing together is
astounding and as a part of a profit
sharing plan i'm always like dude well
that's a
that's a lot of money we spent
but it's worth it
you see what i'm saying so creating
opportunities for people just to get
together and do what you just said just
talk and hang out and it's putting a
coin in a bank and a coin and a bank and
a coin in a bank so that some but one
day someone's going to sit down and go
hey
i gotta tell you something that just
happened or my daughter's not okay or my
wife left me again right and because
you've built up this this cash reserve
over time and so setting up some places
where y'all can just hang out and talk
hang out and laugh hang out and have
some fun together does that make sense
yes it does i think this is incredible
man
i mean you're talking about entire
culture shift and if you want to get
real brave sit down with the with the
brass
with the those the folks who show up
with the clean hard hats and
suits
uh
or their the fancy genes
and say i gave this one talk and we've
had a bunch of people come forward
you'll have a real opportunity to help a
lot of people
and if y'all
go beyond hotlines and set up counselors
or maybe offer to pay for food or set up
a space where we can do a
financial piece class or go through some
of those things we all pay the
registration fee for a couple of
softball leagues so we can start doing
some stuff together
and or have a daycare night where they
can go on dates with their spouse with
their you know their wives or their
husbands and we'll watch the kids but
come up with some things that will help
people's lives be a little bit better
you see what i'm saying and the mental
health stuff begins to
not all of it right not all of it
but man you begin to turn the tide on
some of that stuff i think i think
you're a beautiful soul man
what got you
what got you inspired to have this
conversation in the first place
uh
it was just going through the struggles
of it myself and
i really got it into my heart that i
wanted to
get up there and talk to people
so that way anybody that was wondering
you know what's it like to go through
this
what's it like to go get help
like at least kind of give them a
picture of what that might look like and
i really was just i was so focused on
this is an opportunity to help people
but that's where my head was at and so
good man
well i joked later if if i would have
thought all the way through what i was
getting up there to tell everybody
about myself
if i would have thought about that
beforehand i may not have done it
right
that's that's but the fact that you did
it
i mean
you altered people's trajectory man
because you're brave and i'm grateful
for you thank you for stepping into that
gap there
um
yes set up good system set up a group
set up some tangible let's solve this
problem like money or
oil changes or what i don't know what
the thing is man whatever the thing is
i've i've met with people who started
serving food because they noticed all
their osha complaints were right after
lunch and so the owner of this pipe
fitting company in texas
just started catering organic like
obnoxiously delicious healthy foods and
the osha complaints fell down so
dramatically that they got an
investigation because they were cooking
the books
but it gave the workers an opportunity
to sit down and have lunch together
inside instead of run across and eat at
a gas station and they started eating
healthier foods and then they started
saying hey can my family's come up right
so it changed the system i've seen it
with mental health stuff i've seen it
with play i've seen it with all kinds of
different structures
but it starts with somebody like you
saying not on my watch not anymore i
want my community and i want these folks
lives to be better i want to help so
thank you man thank you so so so much
um stay on the line here we're going to
send you everything and jenna throw in
um chris i'm gonna send you also my new
book i want you to read it
and if you find it of value i'll send
you a few more copies of that one and um
you can pass that out to the folks as
well as you see fit man and hopefully
this will jumpstart you on your way
if you're listening to this
it starts with you where you are
the problems in our world and the
problems in our government the problems
with our country
are not going to be solved with more
screaming they just aren't they're not
going to be solved with more yelling
they just aren't
they're not going to be solved with more
fists they just aren't
they're going to be solved by standing
up and saying hey this is what happened
to me there's a different way you can do
this
who will join me and that's what chris
did
that's what my friends do and that is
what you can do
go make a difference